[Music]
it feels like a very big thing to say
I'm your son and I'm not going to your
wedding did it feel like a big thing
when he said I'm your dad and I'm
leaving your mom and I'm going out on
the playing field to get lucky again
yeah those are those are big things but
I wouldn't go for him I'd go for
[Music]
me yo what's up this is John with the Dr
John aloney show show about your
marriage your mental health your
emotional health your relationships
trying to figure out dating it's a show
that takes all of the most emerging
science combined with ancient wisdom and
delivers it in from a guy who listens to
way too much Social Distortion and old
heavy metal groups and some singer
songwriters I've kind of gotten back
into my Jose Gonzalez phase and my Damen
rice phase but here it is here's my goal
it's
to talk in a language that most of us
regular folks can understand about how
we can make our lives better our
marriages better deal with mental health
deal with our emotional health take
control of our emotions and make the
next right best step and this show is
made up of real people going through
real stuff um in their real lives and
for more than two decades and two phds
and a lot thousands of people I've with
people when the wheels fall off that's
what I that's what I do show up in the
dark and sit with folks and hold their
hand and say let's figure this out and
let's let's go let's let's take the next
right step sometimes that next right
step is a phone call for a therapist
sometimes that next right step is
visiting with an attorney sometimes that
next right step is just looking at love
one saying I'm sorry and what can I do
but my promise
is I'll sit with you and we'll figure it
out if you want to be on the show go to
John dooney.com
askas K fill out the form tell us what
your call is about what you want to talk
about and it will go to Kelly the
producer
extraordinaire and her sidekick
yeah Jenna and they will craft a show
that it it brings the most value to to
who to
y'all sometimes I feel like you're like
oh this one's awesome pretty much it's
what we want to hear excellent excellent
you're like the musicians who are like
when the producers like the executive
producers like the song's not good and
like we don't care we like this song
it's very cool awesome or you can give
us a buzz at 1844 693 3291 leave a
message and we will holla back girl at
you all right so it is we're coming up
on New Year's we're right past Christmas
is that right not yet this is the 22nd
okay the show comes out on December 22nd
we're getting very close
to
Christmas and that means it's close to
to to New Year's which is my favorite
holiday on the planet because we get to
like we have to shower off the stuff we
didn't love about last year and go again
and Kelly's like shower once a year slow
down all right so we've created
questions for humans I created these to
give people an opportunity to put their
phones down stop talking about stupid
stuff like politics and stupid stuff
like this politician's going to save us
they're not this policy is goingon to
save us Pro well it could but probably
not and to have real connection with
real people a skill and an art that
we've lost all right Kelly you've got
the New Year's questions for humans
decks go you picked a couple questions
first one what did you spend way too
much money on this year oo speaking of
that guy right there comedy tickets my
buddy Michael Rish just walked by and he
reignited my love for a standup comedy
this year so I bought way too I bought
too many concert tickets and comedy
tickets this year I bought too many
guitars this year way too many plural
and um I think that's it that's what I
way over spent on oh and Montana Knife
Company I have a problem they make the
greatest knives on planet Earth I have
no affiliation none zero I pay full
price and Kelly I Can't Stop I keep
thinking I need another knife for this
situation cutting bread you know what
works the one I have but I got to have
theirs they're so cool and anyway I've
spent too much money on Montana company
and
um stand up comedy I don't think there's
too much you can't spend too much money
on stand up comedy you can keep spending
but it's all good all right what do you
think um so besides xanx and marijuana
what else did you spend a lot of money
on uh house stuff mainly kitchen because
I had it in my mind since our whole
bottom floor of our house was redone
well if I've got new cabinets new
Counters New appliances I also need all
new things to go with that you can't put
old spoons exactly in a new drawer you
can't need new spatulas to go with that
and hey that thing that I had was ruined
so let me get this thing which is like
way more expensive it's I used it as an
excuse I'm fully aware to buy some
things that I wanted anyway and I used
it as an excuse to upgrade a lot of
things so David Brooks is an
extraordinary author and a um he's a
professor of happiness at Harvard School
of Business
and he talks a lot about the the exhaust
trail of purchasing something that was
really going to matter and he talks
about like when your boss brings you in
and says you crushed it this year 40%
bonus for you that was the that was the
amount he used that is the peak
happiness in that moment you call your
husband and be like guess what when that
check deposits it's you're closer back
to Baseline right so that thought of oh
I'm going to fill all these new drawers
in my new kitchen with new stuff that
felt amazing right
for a minute until the Amazon charges
kept coming through okay but I like
you're eating the same same food soup
with the with a fancier spoon like but I
am cooking said soup with some really
great new cookware does it m does it
matter I mean like like I it's great it
really is nice cuz I got a new induction
stove top I can't use my crap pots and
pants on that
yeah it's like I got a new car we should
repave the driveway
I can't park my new car on an old
driveway it's so awesome I love it all
right next one all right is the week
between Christmas and New Year's Day the
best week of the year or slightly
depressing it is for me it's the best
week of the year I spend the week almost
ex I go feral I live in the woods I come
out to shower and to eat but I live in
the woods it's it's one of the prime
hunting seasons for me but that means I
get to spend extra close time with my
son with um my wife is a her father's a
bass fisherman so she's like she speaks
the language which is pretty amazing
with friends get together and we so it's
one of my favorite times and then I
really get serious about what the next
year is going to look like like
strategically same I love that week um I
take the whole week off the kids are
home we um even my my husband's home in
the same week so all of us are there I
me you know it's like you don't get out
of your pajamas and I spend a lot of
time that week thinking about the next
year and looking forward and with the
kids school with uh um with work and how
I want to it's just a great time to
reset for me I love it and then I'm
ready for by the time we get past that
that I'm like ready for the new year
yeah I've started something a couple
years ago and I kicked it off again this
year where I start November 27th uh 25th
26th 27th and I do the what I would call
the resolution action items now and so I
start exercising a very intentional rout
I get up a little bit earlier I start my
journaling stuff so I do the things that
normally I would wait till January 1 to
do with the intention of I'm already at
full Sprint by the time I hit January 1
and then when my wife and I do our
strategic planning uh Retreat that we do
every year like how was this past we're
already full fully going and I found
that a month lead up to Christmas in
that holiday where I've been taking care
of my health I've been journaling I've
my spiritual life is good it actually
makes me better because normally I would
go all the way up to the 24th and I
crash and then the kids are like ah and
I'm like I could bury you all in the
backyard but by going a month up and
taking care of my sleep and my my
physical life and my marriage all those
things early man it makes the holiday so
good and then I can eat a little bit
more not great because man there's a lot
of sweets that make my heart feel good
so anyway questions for humans go to
John
delone.org you're waiting for the ball
to drop if you're that kind of person um
if you are sitting around waiting for
the firework show get questions for
humans the New Year's deck it gives you
and your friends you and your family
something fun to talk about to plan to
dream about to listen to other folks and
it's really exciting and encouraging go
check them out John del. all right let's
run out to Jasper Indiana and talk to
Shannon what's up Shannon hi how we
doing I am so nervous I didn't think I
was but wow okay don't listen one day
I'm just going to have a show of all the
people I dated in high school and middle
school not all of them just some of them
and they are gonna tell some stories and
then no one's ever gonna be nervous
again I'm just a goofball of the podcast
man I'm glad you're with us what's up
okay so I've been listening to the show
for probably a year now
and I have a question that I can't seem
to answer myself and it keeps popping up
and okay
I don't know what you always talk about
in
your everything what you want your life
to look like what you want your picture
to be what you picture what you want
Etc how do you find what you want I
don't know what I want I know what I
don't
want but how do you strive for a life
that you want because I could dream all
day long but it's not going to be
realistic why not
because I'm not a millionaire living on
a beach with no responsibilities because
all my nannies and housekeepers take
care of everything so if you were to um
actually go there in your fantasy life
this is a great question by the way um
and not in your fantasy like not that
life but like your fantasy life like is
that what you would
want no to sit on a beach and literally
do nothing while people just handed you
drinks
because the research tells me that would
be amazing for about four
days but how do you set realistic wants
need your picture realistically in your
own daily life why are you I I'll answer
that question because I think there's
some really there's some really simple
ways to get there but I'm I'm hung up on
your hangup on the the word
realistic because everyone goes to work
and you get home and you have two hours
with the kids with eating and homework
and bedtime and then before you know it
it's nine o'clock and it's like wow that
escalated where did that go um okay I
guess we'll just unwind and do it all
again
tomorrow like the way you just describe
that sounds
miserable well that makes me
sad well I I think you're hear somebody
who is so so fun to be around is that
true like do people like hanging out
with you yes okay and I think you're
really talented
at hiding from yourself is that fair
very yes so and listen I can tell by the
tone of your voice because here's why in
counseling they train us that everything
is data okay so if somebody's talking to
you and you find yourself like you keep
getting distracted distracted distracted
Ed there's a chance that that's that
person experiences that with everyone
they talk to that everyone they talk to
is just bored out of their mind and so a
good counselor will say hey did people
say you're boring or people struggle to
pay attention to you you instantly I'm
drawn to
you okay like your vocal inflection you
sound fun like I I guarantee you people
want to hang out with you okay so my
question is
this why are you hiding from
or a better word is why are you settling
for
this like what has happened to bring you
to this moment where you're you think
the phrase this is just the way this is
going to
be how do you
balance your
responsibilities as a wife a mom an
employee with fun because you know
what's fun
that that a lot of things are fun rattle
them
off because I don't believe you rattle
them off what's
fun well they are fun but then you throw
the kids in the family say there you go
this is just the way this is what is fun
for Shannon and I'm I'm not picking on
you I'm heading somewhere with this I
like I mean I have fun at the
concerts
eating
snacks with my friends in our pajamas
you know but it's so hard
to balance everything yes and I will
tell you that balance is a 100% LIE
there's no such thing no such thing it's
a complete and utter
manufactured um
lie it's a marketing slogan that's been
sold particularly to why wies
increasingly towards men but for the
last hundred years particularly to
wives um that you can do it all have it
all feel it all experience it all love
it all and if you're off in any of those
it's because you need a new Gadget a new
toy a new thing or because you suck and
just need to get better and it's
nonsense it's just
nonsense so here's I'm I'm gonna start
with this and then I'll actually get to
your actual question okay
okay um the greatest gift you can give
your husband the greatest
gift
is having something that you're truly
passionate about that you're plugged
into that you love that lights you
up the greatest if you don't know what
that is we'll get there I I'll show you
I'll show you how to get there the
greatest thing you can give your
kids is you having friends that you go
to concerts
with not all the time and abandon your
children that's what I'm talking about
but people that you go hang out with
people that bring you Joy and laughter
and make you feel
alive that's the greatest gift because
that makes you non- anxious that makes
you non-electric or in your case that
makes you non this
thymic this just the way this is
lowlevel depression all the time yes
right
yes and the kids absorb that your
husband absorbs that and I'm just going
to throw something out there you can say
no you're kind of missing the boat
here your husband tries to get it back
through
sex or through some sort of Adventure or
he has created a life of his
own the lad okay your kids either bury
their faces in electronics or they try
to cure you through hey Mom hey Mom hey
Mom hey
Mom
yeah okay so here is a great way I think
you're on to it you're so close to it
you're looking past it you ever have
like your kid like is like Mom where's
the fork and you're like right there and
they're like where and their hand is one
centimeter from it that's you okay I
don't want you to think that you're
malfunctioning you're broken or you have
a 100 miles to go you don't you're right
there tell me some things in your life
you're sick of that you don't want
that's a long list give me five of them
rattle them off top to your top of top
of your mind doesn't matter whose
feelings you think you need to protect
you've been protecting people's feelings
your whole freaking life and just for
this one call just
stop tell me what you're sick
of being boring being bored at home okay
just the
everybody just being so grouchy okay um
is everybody mostly your
husband all all three my husband and
kids okay I'm so excited to go home and
you open the door and it's just like
whoa
yeah what else what are you tired
of I don't
know what do you not want you started
the call like I don't know what I do
want but I know what I don't want what
do you not
want I just want people to be fun to be
around it's the day doesn't have to end
at nine or 10 or whatever but it does in
real life because you have to it up and
do it all over
again I don't want a non-ending party
but I just feel like
everyone's down
okay
that's silly no it's listen what you
just described in a beautiful
way I would suggest most of America's
experiencing
it almost everybody is just sick of
it and if we go all the way to the halls
of politicians nobody will tell us what
they're for they will only tell us why
everyone else is
awful and in our all the way down to our
local communities nobody will do
anything but yell and scream and fight
and be angry and inside our homes
everyone's just not happy and I don't
mean happy in fireworks and marshmallows
and you know and cigarettes when you're
in high school I'm talking about happy
like they don't like the lives they've
created for themselves right yes then
they're grouchy about it
okay you that's a perfect word everyone
is Oscar the Grouch and so here's the
exercise okay reverse it it I I envy
people who can just be like I want this
and I'm gonna go get
this that's just not how I
work in my life I got sick of being
unable to
sleep and I got sick of my wife and my
kids having to create create a life away
from me because I was so anxious and
electric all the
time and so in this situation I'm your
husband I'm so sick of being so grouchy
in my own home how do I stop this I
didn't know what I wanted but I knew I
had to stop feeling like this and so
reverse engineering is a great way to
find out you're not that far off but I
want you to spend some time actually
writing down what am I tired of in my
own home
because if you have a a house surrounded
by grouchy people and you are your
natural inclination is laughter and joy
and let's go do something fun or my gosh
the kids are in bed let's close the door
and peel the wallpaper off this place it
I just want to I got to do some work
honey and you feel trapped in your own
home then your body just shuts the whole
thing down right y okay let's reverse
engineer it let's write down and let's
be honest for probably the first time
and you said there's a long list I want
you to make that long list tired of
everybody being so bored and grouchy I'm
tired of not having enough money for
this I'm tired of I'm just can't handle
write that crap
down and then I want you to make a
column that's one column and then next
to it you can do an Excel spreadsheet if
you're a super nerd or you can do it on
a yellow pad if you're from The 14th
Century like me and I want you just to
draw a line to the things that you can
actually do something
about okay so that's step one what of
these things that I want to be different
in my life can I actually do something
about okay that's step one here's step
two the more they
things the more it ends up in accusation
land so you take your husband out for
breakfast or for lunch like I always
tell everybody to do and you say I need
you to stop doing this and stop doing
this and stop doing this well now you
started throwing punches and he has to
he has to swing back or he has to Turtle
up and just take it okay so I don't want
you to start with you need to do a you
need to do B you need to do
c i want you to start with something
completely different and I've talked
about this a little bit publicly and I
need to do a better job of it when my
wife sat across the table from me and
this is years ago and we were deciding
are we like grown-ups are we still going
to be married like let's be adults is
this is this where we how is this where
this thing
ends and we both agreed no this is where
this thing's going to restart and re be
reimagined but when we did that we
started with something that is very not
me and is very not her we started with
our feelings
first how do I want this house to feel
when I walk into
it and then from the feeling part what
has to be true and so I said I want to
feel safe in my own body in my own house
because I grew up in the house of a
homicide detective and it any moment it
could all come down right I wanted a
couple of acres and I wanted a huge
Garden
and I wanted to become a better Hunter
does that mean I'm a little bit of a
prepper a little bit chill Shannon right
but my wife said cool so here's what has
to happen for that we have to make x
amount of
dollars which means for a season we have
to sacrifice X Y and Z for that to
happen when we had that conversation and
we had a road map it didn't start with
you need to make more money or I need to
work more it started with I want to feel
safe and my whole body went
whoosh and both of us said we want when
we open our front door we want our house
to feel um or actually when you come up
we have a long driveway into the woods I
mean there is Banjo a plan out there and
you turn into our long driveway my wife
said I want to feel like I'm coming home
and I said when we open the front door I
want it to feel like laughter and
warmth so what has to be true she said
when you get home before me will you
turn the porch lights on so I can see
them coming from half a mile away
done for it to feel warm and full of
laughter the house can't be full of
dishes John you can't have piles all
over the freaking house can't be dirty
clothes just dropped from the opening to
the front door all the way to back
done see what I'm
saying so the question is sitting down
with your husband saying what has to be
true in this home that you don't have to
feel so
grouchy or what what has to be true in
your life that makes you have to treat
our kids like this treat me like this
treat the sacredness of our home like
this and we're going to start with
feelings first does that make
sense
yes why does that scare you so
much because my husband has a lot of
ability to shut it
down without
proceeding as adult yeah so here's the
problem
you have to make space for your husband
won't come along for the
ride and I want to challenge
you to tell him I me and our
kids cannot
accept what may become verbally
abusive we
can't I'm asking you not to shut down
when we have this conversation today do
you prom promis me
that and if he says uhuh I ain't doing
that then you know in your heart you got
bigger issues in your marriage right
right do you have bigger issues in your
marriage our biggest issue is
communication
okay I think this is a great way to
begin to get everybody on the same page
especially as we enter into a new
year and so when you sit down and say
hey let's go on a long date a 2 or three
hour date preferably in the morning cuz
people aren't
exhausted I want you to make a lot of IE
statements here's what I want to feel
like in my
home here's what I want our sex life to
be like here's what I want my
relationship with our kids to be like I
would love to hear from you H
husband what do you want this to feel
like and then how do we combine these
things and how do we get
there and if he shut down and says this
is stupid I ain't doing this my oh my
gosh if you would just shut up then none
of this would happen if that's the
response then you tell them I'm going to
go see a counselor this breakfast is
over because this isn't working and I'm
not saying leave him I'm saying you've
got much bigger issues in your marriage
because you have a man a husband who has
no interest in loving his wife you have
a man or a husband who has no interest
in building a long-term relationship
with his kids you have a husband who is
interested in being a whiny brat
and husbands if you're listening to this
and you are a
grouch
stop fix it get the healing you need oh
when I work hard I get h no your kids
don't deserve that your wife doesn't
deserve that
stop so Shannon my guess is there's a
much bigger fish to fry here but I think
it's an amazing exercise for you to
start I'm going to send you a copy of
building a non-anxious life my brand new
book I want you to use it as a road map
in my home these six PL these six
stages these six
choices where are we
off actually I'm going to send you two
ask your husband if we'll read it with
you so I'm just asking you to love me
enough just to read this book with me
and I want us to use these six daily
choices as a road map to bring peace
into our house and tell them I love you
so much that I want more for you in your
life is than you just to be exhausted
and grouchy and not even like being in
your own
home I want that to be different do
you thank you so so much for the call
Shannon I'm grateful for
you grateful for you we'll be right
back hey it's deloney and the holidays
are coming up and holidays can be
stressful have you ever found yourself
hiding in a closet from all the chaos
and the noise and the political opinions
or been sitting in your car with your
hands gripping the steering wheel just
looking up to the sky saying why God why
I know you have and I have too so I'm a
Christian guy and listen regardless of
where you find yourself in the Christian
faith tradition you can find peace with
hallow the number one Christian Prayer
app on planet Earth hallow has Christmas
prayers and meditations this holiday
season Bible stories and peaceful
holiday music to help you de-stress
While You Work Shop drive or hang out
with with family which are times you
probably need peace the most I even
listen to some of the music while I work
out their prey 25 challenge offers daily
devotions based on the writings of CS
Lewis and these writings are voiced by
Liam niss or you can listen to scripture
read by Jonathan roomy from The Chosen
and you can get hallow free for three
months at hall.com
dealone find peace for free for three
delone
all right we're back let's go out to
Kansas City and talk to se T what's up
Scott thanks Dr John it's such an honor
to be on the show with you I'm grateful
for you man it's an honor for me what's
up all right here's what's up so here's
the question and then we'll Circle back
around for more context but should I
attend my dad's upcoming wedding even
though I believe he is is not a healthy
person has no business getting married
and I feel sorry for his uh girlfriend
now fiance cuz internally I am screaming
why are you even marrying my
Dad
wow that sounds like there is a I'm
smiling because wow that's a lot dude
what' your dad
do what does he what did he do yeah what
what brought your relationship
here uh that has been a very long
road um most
recently he and my mom separated about
two years ago and then got officially
divorced about this time last year and
then the ink was hardly dry on the
documents before he was telling me he
was out there looking for a
girlfriend
um growing up
I have come to
realize he was emotionally and verbally
abusive um never physical but
emotionally verbally very controlling in
kind of like a roundabout manipulative
Sinister type of way you just feel
crushed like there's no power there for
you um and also you know my mom would
have dealt with that and more too before
they separated so how old are you
now I am 28
okay um do you have contact with your
dad do y' all talk
regularly sem I I do have contact he
lives in the area um I think over this
like this calendar year we may have
talked slash got them together for
family events
one
two three four maybe five times so you
don't have a relationship with
them no okay okay so so so give me well
do this get why would you
go why would I go
yep because it feels like a very big
thing to
say I'm your son and I'm not going to
your
wedding did it feel like a big thing
when he said I'm your dad and I'm
leaving your mom and I'm going out on
the playing field to get lucky
again yeah did it feel like a big thing
when he
said I don't give a crap what you think
about X and Y and Z you need to do this
you should do this I can't believe you
did that you failed this and he's been
doing that to you your whole freaking
life yeah those are those are big things
so at some point you're going to have to
decide
I'm going to continue to prop up my
dad's emotional health for him because
he is too much of a coward to go get the
help he needs to be able to hold himself
up and that's what You' have done for
him his your whole your whole life and
his whole time of knowing
you
fair yep very
fair so I can't tell you whether to go
to this wedding or
not I am somewhat of a
peacekeeper so I'd probably just go but
I wouldn't go for him I'd go for
me but also if you said dude I can't go
to this I can't be a part of this he
ditched my mom and he's already getting
remarried to' be a slap in the face to
my mom and more importantly I'm
not I'm not going to be his little Pat
me on the head approver boy
anymore like that's not my job he's a
grown
man and if he still needs needs his
little boy's approval to blow up the
family and to start a new family I'm
that's not my job anymore I'm not doing
that anymore if you said I'm not going
I'd highfive you for that
too but I don't want you to go out of
cowardice out of I don't want to make
him
mad right I don't want to hurt his
feelings because he hasn't given a crap
about your feelings
ever
and it's probably fair to say in times
when he pretended to care about your
feelings it was because he couldn't
handle your bad feelings not because he
actually cared that you were hurting is
that
fair yeah I think that's fair a lot of
the times that come to my mind like I
think it was more like kind of like
damage control like here let me come fix
this issue with my son or let me work on
this issue because the result is
otherwise it would look bad for me right
um and so I don't want to hit my kid I
know he didn't hit you but I'm just
using that because it's an outlandish
example I don't want to hit my kid not
because it's wrong because I'm going to
hurt a child because I'm going to make
my child unable to understand what Love
Actually is feels like in a connected
deep resounding way but I'm not going to
hit my kid because I don't want people
to think I'm a bad
guy one of those is noble and honorable
and one of them is grossly
self-serving right
yep yeah so I think after when you live
with somebody like that you develop
um crippling over
thinking how' you
know because I've sat with people like
you for 20 years and you Loop and loop
and loop because here's why you've been
trying to please a boss who has
no um you've been trying to make a boss
happy without a job
description and on Monday you sell five
things and your boss is like that's
amazing and then Tuesday you sell five
things and he's like you suck you should
have sold 15 and Wednesday you knock on
his door to tell him you sold five
things and he does even answer
it and so what you develop is this
spinning thought wheel for lack of
better terms and there's some actual
biochemical processes going on here but
you develop a manal spinning thought
wheel trying to figure out the way you
can bridge the gap to his
heart because what happens with little
boys especially but happens with little
girls too is when you have a father like
you had and let's be honest he provided
food do you have shelter
yes right so there is there is a good
side to this you learned some stuff and
my guess is you've probably become very
sophisticated in how you manage
workplace politics is that
fair uh it depends maybe
okay
so you've been trying to answer the
question your whole life like Dad do you
love me what is it why why why do we
keep having to why can't you
just and I tell you this wedding isn't
going to solve
that no it it's not going to end me and
my siblings are just waiting for when
it's going to blow up again well it's I
I wouldn't wait I'd go on with my
life and you see what I'm saying like
y'all are waiting for the explosion
you've been waiting for this explosion
your whole lives and it always always
comes but what you do is you don't live
your life for 19 months at a time cuz
you're got your breath
held and you let stupid crass evil
things be said at the five Gatherings
you get together every year and you he
shows up late or shows up drunk or shows
up like this or talks to your mom like
that and she goes it's fine guys it's
fine and you hold your breath and then
it blows up and then it all exhales and
what you realize is oh holding my breath
for 19 months or 24 months or 2 years or
3 years or whatever didn't prevent
this and so I'll tell you you and your
siblings should just as the great Jay-Z
said brush your shoulders off and move
on go live your
life and when it blows up which we all
know it will and your dad calls blaming
her for this what you can say yeah Dad
of course we all I mean what do you want
me to say we all saw this coming you
know what I mean but you will have been
so much further down the road than you
just pulling off the side of the road
with a door open and your blinkers on
waiting for him to blow up his life so
he can come back and get back in your
car because that's not your
job
right so what I'm saying sounds mean but
I also hope you hear it as
empowering yeah no I hear it that way
that's definitely something that as I've
worked on this and therapy for the B
last year or two like coming around to
the realization that like no like it is
boundaries and it does feel mean it
looks mean but it's it's boundaries it's
keeping me safe and letting him just
live his life and and here here's here's
the big question has he asked your
opinion on on any of
this he has one time asked me about what
he think what I think about his
relationship with his girlfriend
what' you
say I told him that I thought he was
moving too fast that this wasn't a good
idea that I think he needed to work on
himself more and if behavior is a
language what did he say back to
you he said he doesn't care booy yo
that's what I'm talking
about hey asked your opinion and when
you didn't validate
him he said I don't want anything to do
with you you're
wrong so he took your your wisdom which
is incredibly wise and he took your your
thoughts and your thinking and your care
and love for him and he used it as
toilet
paper that's
it and so he's not coming back to you
and saying hey like for real though like
is this a good idea cuz I won't do it if
you guys think this is too fast I feel
like um me and your mom we were separate
for we lived in the same house but we've
been apart for 10 years I feel alive
again is this too fast and y'all go yeah
Dad you're not
okay and he goes all right dude I'm
gonna go talk to
somebody yeah man I would hold that
dude's hand i' I'd ride to the end of
Earth with that
guy but the guy that just goes around to
his children trying to get them to Pat
him on the back for how great he is when
he's just destroyed your our mom's life
and
um he's trying to drag us along with him
into the future I'm I don't know I'm not
GNA play so after more talking I I take
back my earlier thing that I'd probably
just go I probably wouldn't
go I would though and this is just me um
I'm a pretty direct I don't say
confrontational but like I'll just don't
mind having hard conversations I'd
probably sit down with them and say Hey
Dad I I've thought about it over and
over again again I can't I'm not going
to I'm not going to go to your
wedding yeah Dad it doesn't feel right
to me feels very very quick um I feel
like you got a lot of healing that needs
to happen and this feels fast and so I'm
G sit this one out you can tell them I'm
G sit this one out I'll catch the next
one that'd be a great joke but
um all I have to say man um all jokes
aside I'm heartbroken for you this is
isn't how it's supposed to
be and you've probably held your mother
she's wept over last year and it's not
how it's supposed to be and you've
probably uncovered some things in
therapy that about how your dad treated
you and let's be honest about how your
mom just has stood by and watched some
of it happen which is scary too and
frustrating and traumatic
also and it's not supposed to be that
way I'm sorry my friend but here's the
deal I can't answer this for you I can
just tell you what I would do
um I don't think you lose either way
whether you you go or whether you skip
it the only way you lose is if you make
a decision out of fear or out of
pandering or out of
cowardice I'm going to go cuz I don't
want him to get mad at me again then
you've lost not cuz you went not cuz you
didn't go because once again you gave
him the keys to your life time for you
to take back your own life make sure to
call my brother we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's deloney this time of year
there can be a lot of anxiety and a lot
of drama but it can also be great but
could also be a mix of everything right
especially when it comes to giving gifts
maybe your family makes super thoughtful
handmade things or they expect you to
spend a million dollars or maybe you
just like experiencing time together or
pick up random gift cards last minute
things like gift giving can make us
bananas so no matter how hectic it gets
especially around gift giving remember
to take care of yourself whether it's
going easier on yourself during tough
moments or having to say hey we don't
have enough money to buy all these gifts
or treating yourself to a Day of Silence
remember to give yourself some love this
holiday season and if things get too
heavy if thinking about dealing with
your family and all of the drama gets to
be too much give better help a try
better help us flexible because it's
online so it can fit into your busy
holiday schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get match with the
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapists at any time for no extra
charge in this season of Chaos in love
and sadness and all of it rolled up to
one give yourself what you need with
better help visit betterhelp.com deloney
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.
/one all right we're back let's go to
Justine in Providence Road Island hey
Justine what's happening hi Dr Delani
how are you good how are you oh I'm
hanging in hanging in all right what's
up you could complain then you sound
like one of our politicians what's up um
yeah so I guess my my main question is
how do I mourn my mother who is still
very much alive and um how do I second
question is how do I get my heart to
agree with my brain in that it's time to
end that
relationship what what has happened that
brought you here that's one of the most
sacred relationships a mother and her
daughter what happened yeah and I'm I'm
gonna try to get to this without getting
emotional but hey get as emotional as
you can I mean that's this this is few
things are more emotional Than This
Moment is having a funeral for somebody
is still alive yeah it's it's been awful
um so I guess long story short my mom is
um she has has battled a prescription um
pill addiction for about 13 14 years oh
man what that's the devil dude it's the
devil it's it's awful and on top of that
she is borderline personality
disorder and so um you know she had me
very young I had a very tumultuous
childhood I've um finally kind of come
to a place in my life I'm 34 now uh
where I am married to a wonderful man I
have a stable home we just had our first
child five months ago um congrats how's
that going thank you oh he's he's just
amazing he's wonderful I know he
probably is how are
you I'm you know I'm doing really well
with all of that but the the problem is
that I had even though I she's been
crazy crazy for my whole life and then
when the pill started it was like a
whole different kind of crazy I still
somehow had this idea in my head that if
I was able to make my life as perfect as
possible and um you know have give her
the beautiful grandchild and and do all
these things that she would see that and
want to be well so that she could be a
part of it and even though I knew that
wasn't reality I there was still part of
me that was like well you know just keep
doing this and that and and here I am
you know
thinking well maybe my mom will show up
for me and she just she just hasn't and
now that I'm a mother myself
I'm I just it's different now because
you know she has been violent and the
cops get involved every other week and
the drugs back and forth and I I can't
have my kid around that I I can't have
my kid exposed to those things and now
I'm just Justine Justine this has never
been your job and I'm so sorry it has
been for 34 years yeah it's been awful
like I've had to have her um committed
on a 5150 before flown across the
country to put her under
rehab um but listen this has never been
your
fault I know you know that
intellectually I'm trying to say it to
where your heart can hear it right and
that's the problem it was never your
job and now let me tell me if I'm wrong
you're holding this beautiful
five-year-old five-month-old
baby and it becomes real in a different
way it's very intellectual when you're a
kid and your mom and you're trying to
survive and you know how to talk to your
mom and de escalator and things like I
don't want her to go to jail and I don't
want her to die like those are all
intellectual Pursuits they're very very
real intangible mhm but then when you
hold your
baby it's like how in the
hell could you choose all that over this
right yes absolutely it almost makes you
insane because that math just simply
doesn't compute yes and then you go from
oh my gosh I've been keeping you alive
for 29 years or 30 years or 33 years or
34 years to rage Fair yes yes yeah how
dare you when you see how innocent and
beautiful and wonderful this is right
how dare you yes and
so I mean the hardest question is how I
mean when are you going to let
go here's what you're doing I'm gonna
give you a crass example you keep
showing up at your local Burger King
walking in and making
burgers and they're like you you don't
work here and you're like n I'm great at
this I can make good Whoppers yeah and
then you go work to register and they're
like you literally don't work here
you're like ah I'm good at this though
and you are pretty good at
it and every time you leave they're like
I mean I'll take the free labor but she
doesn't even work here it's not her job
yep so when yeah you talk about you
talked about your baby doesn't deserve
to be around this you don't want your
hband around this
crap when are you going to start caring
about
Justine well and that's that's the thing
is that you know my my head tells me
that my head's like you don't deserve
this you know she has through her
behavior has opted out of relationship
with me she doesn't want to be well and
you know that's her saying I don't care
I want to live my life and be a lunatic
and that's just what it's going to be
but my heart is saying well it's only
mother you've got well one day she's not
going to be here and you're going to be
sorry you couldn't just put up with it
you know and like I I'm G tell you
something
awful can I tell you an awful truth yes
you can when she's gone you will feel a
relief and a piece that you did not know
existed I I already yeah I understand
that you will beat yourself up for the
next decade out of guilt for feeling
that way
yeah you will exhale in a way that you
did not know was
possible and then you'll feel so bad for
doing it
yep I I've anticipated
that yeah it's just awful it is I mean
I've cut all Communications with her and
you know it's holidays and it's
especially hard around the holidays just
not not having your mom not having your
your kids spend their first Christmas
with their grandmother and and
it's her that left you right okay and I
have a special special place in my soul
for people who struggle with addiction
I've walked with them I've sat with them
I have it and most of my career has been
spent picking up relational
shrapnel from the path of Destruction
people struggling with addiction leave
on their loved ones their kids their
spouses right so I have a deep
compassion and they also have a
reality okay
one of the hardest things in the world
to do I think is to watch a loved one
who's an adult make choices that will
destroy them and you they do not want
your support or help or
input that's correct it's devastating
it's a slow motion train wreck that
you're watching and you here's what
makes it worse you you you could stop
it sort
of as your uh nonsens IAL um control
over every variable of the world lies to
you and tells you you can you can't stop
it Justin you can't you can't what you
can do is get yourself stuck between
that brick wall that's coming and the
train and get yourself killed
too you can destroy your
marriage you can put your kid in
situations it makes your kid incredibly
unsafe right right yeah and not that I
can't allow either of those things
that's right so here's I'm gonna give
you the same advice I given a thousand
times on this show
and um I'm going to add one caveat to it
and it's going to require some homework
from you okay okay are you willing to
try absolutely and listen if this tanks
if this does not work I want you to call
me back I've never had somebody say it
doesn't work but I'm sure they've tried
it and it hasn't but every single person
who's done this has said I hate the fact
that this worked as eff as U effectively
as it did okay it's going to take three
weeks start now and um we're recording
this show about three weeks four weeks
out outside of Christmas if you start
right now you can land this plane right
on Christmas
Day cool mhm it will not feel good all
right okay I want you number one to set
a timer for 20 to 30 minutes you get to
pick and I want you to write a letter to
your
mother about all the amazing things she
G she gave you she brought
you and it could be backhanded
compliments like I'm so strong because I
had to learn how to navigate the mental
health system and I had to learn how to
do impatient paperwork for my mom and I
was
12 it made you made me you taught me
what love looks like because you kept
coming back even though you were stoned
out of your mind or you wouldn't take
your meds right like I want you to write
a love letter to your mom saying thank
you okay that's week one I want you to
write that on a Monday and I want you to
read that letter every day the rest of
the week
okay yep second week I want you to write
a
letter uh that starts to your mom how
dare
you and this one might be more than 30
minutes but this is where the anger and
the frustration and the rage and the
Heartbreak come out on
paper yeah remember that time you left
me when I was seven remember that time
you had three men spending the night in
our house and fill in the
blank yeah you shouldn't have done that
to a little girl you shouldn't have you
see what I'm saying I want I want you to
write that
letter okay okay yeah the following week
I want you to write a letter dear
Mom let me tell you about my life
now I don't you to describe how amazing
your husband is what he brings to you
how he makes you feel stable whole loved
and
seen I want you to tell your mom about
your new
baby how amazing the birth process was
did she probably did she miss it yeah
yeah that you missed was amazing and
here's what this letter is it is
Mom here's the daughter you raised
here's what you're going to miss and I'm
going to miss you this is the Heartbreak
letter but it's the truth-telling
letter okay yeah and as we roll into
Christmas this is number four four and
this is the hard one and you're like the
other three kind of
suck this is number four it's hard
because it's it's into the
future I want you to write a letter to
your new
baby and I want you to read that letter
I want you to record yourself reading
that letter to your
baby dear
sweetheart you've brought me light
don't you tell that baby what their life
is going to be like how they're going to
be loved how they're going to be seen
and when Mom's not well which you're
going to have seasons when you're not
well too that you're going to go get
help I want you to make commitments I
want you to talk to that baby through
that letter and I want there to be a
recording of it yeah okay and I think
that could be a magical Christmas gift
for a what will be almost
six-month-old
yep is that cool okay absolutely and I
want you to look around the room on
Christmas morning and your mom won't be
there and it's okay to weep yeah it's
okay to be really sad
and like that third letter it's okay to
be like man this is what we got this is
our picture we're going to paint
it we thought we were painting
Landscapes well we're painting dinosaurs
now right yeah if you want to be a real
gangster when you write these letters I
want you to read them out loud to your
husband maybe a couple of your
girlfriends I want you to read it out
loud okay as the great David Kessler
says I say this all the time grief
Demands a witness yeah bringing somebody
else in and just reading it out loud
there probably is some stories your
husband has no idea that you experienced
is that
fair
yeah you probably have three or four
close girlfriends that love you up
upwards and downwards and sideways and
backwards and forwards and they don't
know what you've been through yeah
yeah so tell them hey Tuesday we're
going for coffee I had to write this
letter because this on this
YouTube show told me to do this
and I got to read it to you and it's
tough and so y'all bring grown-up drinks
and we're going to do this right okay um
and expect to have both things on
Christmas morning
relief
peace and
grief
heartbreak mom should be there Grandma
should be there for babies first and
she's not and thank God she didn't bring
that chaos
here if you are struggling with
addiction and you happen to be listening
to the show whether it's pornography
whether
it's pills whether it's whatever it's
alcohol
gambling give yourself the gift of
Freedom this Christmas and call somebody
please you're worth so much more and as
you've heard from
Justine you can't get clean for your for
other people you can only get clean for
yourself but man your people in your
life that you love and who love you they
deserve that
too make a call Justine you're awesome
anytime I can help holler at me I'd love
to hear how this process goes call me
after Christmas and let me
know both and proud of you we'll be
right
back hey what's up deloney here listen
you and me and everybody else of the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point and
my my new book building a non- anxious
life you'll learn the six daily choices
that you can make to get rid of your
anxious feelings and be able to better
respond to whatever life throws at you
so you can build a more peaceful
non-anxious life get your copy today at
john.com
all right as we wrap up today's show we
have everyone's favorite installment
episode what do we call them is it an
installment I'm the problem is it me go
Kelly all right this is from Lisa in
Missouri am I the problem should we do a
secret DNA
test is this a Missouri question or what
on our three-month-old
nephew my husband's brother surprised us
all last Christmas with news that his on
again off again Girlfriend Was Pregnant
the family was shocked but supportive
but his parents privately told us that
they were going to run a DNA test on the
baby to confirm that he was the father
father now the baby's here and he's
adorable and the grandparents bonded
with him and said that they're not going
to do the test I still think it's an
important question to know for certain
who the father is and better to know now
than when he's 10 or 20 years old right
is it terrible that we've thought about
doing this test secretly and sending it
in to get a definitive
answer ladies and gentlemen I quit I
quit I quit humanity and I quit the show
I quit
everything um
yes you're the problem please do not run
secret DNA tests on your
nephew
please
please just
don't if you're holding this
nephew and almost like in a Saturday
Night Live kind of way it's super clear
that your brother-in-law or brother is
not the
father take him out for a beer and point
that
out
right but please God help you don't run
secret DNA tests on your family members
just don't do
that is that right Kelly what do you
think oh 100% I mean there might even be
a legality issue here I don't know that
but I'm sure you could find a strand of
baby hair and just run it I I know but
no I don't know enough about DNA test
that's the dad that's the parents job if
they want to do it or he'll have to deal
with that when he gets older but man
talk about dropping a bomb in the middle
of your family you know what if the
grandparents and everybody's happy with
this just love love the child just love
him cuz what are you g to do if it's not
his what do you how do they tell them
yeah as an aunt and an uncle what are
you going to be like well then you can't
call life is not a Mari poit show you're
not going to be like hey everybody pass
the spaghetti and you are not the father
exactly what are you going to do are you
not going to love the child cuz what if
he knows it's not his what if in his
head the father knows this isn't my baby
but I don't care yeah I'm raising this
child not their call please dear God
don't if you ever think hey unasked by
my family members let's do something
secretive just answer is probably no no
no unless it's calling CPS cuz you were
witnessing child abuse other than that
or elder abuse other than that just love
that sweet little baby love that sweet
little baby and if you can tell oh my
gosh there's no way no
way just smile at your
brother-in-law and say wow what a great
guy taking care of this
baby America and to my friends I've got
lots of friends in Community in Missouri
I'm not hating on you just making a
joke but God Bless America geez
Louise stay in school and don't don't do
drugs love you guys
bye